みなさんこんにちは福島県いわき市から来ました
高校3年生の佐藤陸です僕は毒舌を吐くつもりありますので少し頃をつかせて聴いて
ください
いきなりですが
東北の中高生若者の役割ってなんだと思いますか
どこにでもいる若者でありません東北の中高生若者です
私はそれを見つけました
4年前2011年3月11日東日本大震災が起きました
皆様ご存知の通り本当に大きな被害を受けました
しかし私は幸いなことに家が崩れるわけでもなく
津波にのまれるわけでもなく
比較的被害は少ない方でした
ですがそんな経験から私の一つの萌えがずっと心に引っかかっていました
それが無力感でした
震災から1週間くらいたった時に地元のスーパーがやっとオープンしたんです
そこで父と2人で買い出しに行きましたたくさんの水やたくさんの食料買い込んでレジ
に並ぼうとしました
すると一人のおばあさんが両手に1個ずつ立った2つのカップラーメンを持ってレジに
向かっていったんです
どうしてだ
私たちより絶対に
体力があるわけではないそれにこれから何があるかもわからない
それなのにカップラーメンに行こっ
でもわたしたちは自分たちの水や食料
彼女に渡すことができませんでした
きっとこの事は他の人からすればでも仕方ない
緊急事態だし知らない人だったんでしょしょうがないよ
そういう風に言われると思います
でもやはり私にはこのうりょく感がずっと残っていました
そんな想いを抱えたまま私は中学3年生となり
生徒会長として
学校の生徒会をどう動かしていこうか迷っていました
そんな時に他県からメッセージフラッグが届きました
そのメッセージフラッグには私たちのこと本当に心配して応援しようという熱い想いが
込められていました
それを見て私たちは
できることってこれなんじゃないか
中高生私は中学生ができるってこれこの子じゃないか
っていうふうに思ったんです
私たちの中学校は海の近くにありましたので
メッセージフラッグという形ではなく大量バターっていう呼ぶことにしました
そして思い思いのデザインを元内の魚のようなイメージはなく本当にこれはあれですね
手をつないでいる
a ですね
思い思いのこれから目指していきたいトークの姿
これから目指していきたい自分たちの地域の姿を知るし地元の被害を受けた商店や
そして海上保安部など本当にた付けてくださった方に贈るという活動しました
私たちが受け取ったメッセージフラッグは他県からのものでしたが私たちが作ったのは
同じ被災をした地域から中学生が大人の方々に送るというものでした
これは地元の給食センターに送った時の写真です
この給食センターも本当に大きな被害を受けまして私たちは結局中学3年生の1年間
給食を食べることができませんでした本当に大きな被害があったので給食が熱くれ
なかったからです
でも私たちはこの給食本当にもう一度食べたかっただからこういう風な絵を書いて寄贈
しました
この大人の方には
君たちのような若い世代の人がこうやって応援してくれと本当に元気が出る
ありがとう
そういったことはもらいました
中学生でもできることってあるんだな
若い世代ができることであるんだなというふうに思いました
そしてそんな思いを抱えたまま高校生になりました
中学生の経験からある程度の自信はついて何かできることはないか
また新しいことを模索していた時に oecd 東北スクールというプロジェクトに
出会いました
これは東北の魅力を世界に発信するというイベントをこのフランスのパリ f 8の下
で行うというものです
そして2年半の準備期間の間にプレゼンテーションや資金を調達する方法
そして pr など学校では学べないことを勉強するそのイベントを作り上げて行く
途中でそういった不学習もするといったプロジェクトです
ああああああ
私はこのプロジェクトでリーダーを務めました
リーダーになってから本当にたくさんのことを悩みました
資金を調達しろ
イベントをつくれそういう具体的な仕事内容があるわけでありません
またリーダーということで同じ立場の人間がいません
いつも孤独でした
自分はリーダーとしてどうやってこのチームをまとめていくべきかどうやってこの
プロジェクトを成功に導いていくべきか
常にそういうことを考えていました
特に私が困った課題大変だった課題がメンバー間の温度差でした
こんな大きなプロジェクトを進めていくようにメンバー間に温度差があっていいのか
私の時にメンバーにきつく当たりました厳しい言葉で終了しました
ですがあると気づいたんです
住んでいるところも違うところも違えば年代も違う性別の違う
そして震災体型も違う
そんなメンバーがそんなメンバーの思いに下がるのは当たり前のことだ
そう気づいたんです
それから私はメンバーと密にコミュニケーションをとるようにしそのメンバーの軸に
ある本当にその人の高圧なっている思いをくみ取り
それをイベントにどうやって活用していくべきかそういったアプローチでリーダーとし
て動く
動いて行きました
結果イベントは大成功全員のボルテージを max にしてイベントを行うことができ
たと思います
これはステージの前の会人が集まってきた写真です
これはほんの一部なんですがこのイベントの途中ではなんとこのイベント2日間を行っ
たんですがなんと2日間で15万人を動員しました
この写真すごいと思いませんかほとんどの人が現地の人です
お客さんです
上から撮った写真ですが本当にわかりやすいすごい構図だと思います
誰が撮ったんでしょ僕です
使わせていただきました
こんなのイベントが
実際に成功するまで
なんだかんだ言って僕は自分がリーダーとしてやっていくことに
本当にちゃんとできているのかいつも不安でした
本当にこのイベントを成功したけれど僕はちゃんと導いてくれたのかな
一緒にみんなで頑張ってこれたのかな
そういう不安でいっぱいでした
しかしイベントが終わるとみんなが僕を胴上げしてくれたんです
ちょっと高く上がってないに見えるのは気のせいでしょ
そして胴上げしてくれた後に
riku さんがリーダーでよかった riku さんみたいなリーダーになりたい
そしていくは東北作るそのものだった
そういった言葉をもらいました
僕の努力が間違ってなかった僕がこのスクールで頑張って行動してきたことは間違い
じゃなかったんだ
頑張ってきてよかった
そう思い涙が止まりませんでした
このような経験から私は遠くの中高生トークの若者な
a の役割遠くの中高生若者の役割というものを
行動してみるこの一言なのかなというふうに感じました
私は無力感を感じ
そして中学生の雪中学校の時生徒会で
大漁旗を作るという行動をしてみました
その行動からステップアップして高校生になった時にこのプロジェクトに参加すると
いう行動を起こしてみました
そしてその中でリーダーとしてイバーの道を血だらけになりながらも行動し続けてき
ました
その結果が今の僕を方作っています
3年間約3年間の活動の間に
ずっと応援してくれていた大人の方にこんなことをやりました
もちろんプレゼンテーションとか人と鼻人との話し方スキルの面も成長したけどなんか
表情が違うよね
すごく大人になった
きっと本当にたくさんの経験苦難を乗り越え
そしてたくさんの人とやったから
その私たち私の表情にも変化が見られたのかなと思います
そして
その変化を生み出したのも結局僕が行動してきたからその結果だと思っています
ではなぜ私たちのは私たち若者トークの中高生が行動しなくてはならないのでしょうか
私は
いろんな企業さにプレゼンテーションに行きましたこのプロジェクトに参加して
ください
そういった時に必ず言われた事が君たちみたいな中高生がこんなことやってるの見た
ことがないよ凄いねじゃあ協力するよ
私たちにとっては少し無謀な行動でした
無謀な一歩でしたでも中高生がこういったアクションを起こす行動するということに
本当に大きな価値があるんです
そしてその価値を見出した大人の方はじゃあ一緒にやろう
巻き込まれてくれるんです私たちには
あるアクションを起こしてそれを巻き込むみんなを巻き込む力があります
最近よくありますよね例えば中学生高校生とコラボした食べ物食品とか
文房具とか中高生にしか生み出せないアイディアとか
価値っていうのはあるんです
自分なんか出来るわけがないそう思っている人もたくさんいると思います
けどその壁を一歩超えて踏み出してみると
あれすごいアイディアちゃんあれは面白いねじゃあみんなでやろうよ
そういう輪が広がります
もう一つ僕が言いたいことがあります
僕は
このトークスクールの活動を通していろんな人と出会い
どこ出身なのとこから来たの言われます僕は
あっ福島県いわき市から来ました東北から来ましたと言いますそうすると残念ながら
一部の人はあ東北があ福島か大丈夫今
今危ないんじゃないの地震は津波は原発わっ
そういうネガティブなイメージで答えられるんですね
そこで私が
答えるのはいつも本当に大変でしたでも今すごくみんな頑張っていて本当にいいところ
です
今度もしよかったら来てください
案内します
でも多分今のトークの若者中にはそうなんです危ないんですよ
怖くてしょうがないんですよ
そうやって答える人もいると思います
でも東北で育ちトークで青春ずでお過ごし
そのことって自分とは切っても切り離せアイデンティティーだと思うんです
そのことをプラスにしなくてどうするんですか
って僕はずっと持ってプラスのイメージで答えてきました
せっかく自分自身の愛電池
東北ってことを誇れるようにするためには
まずその投稿担うべき私たち若者が
その東北を本当にプレイティ部に作り上げていくためにも
行動する
その行動こそが自分たちにとってもそして遠くにとっても大きなアクションになるん
です
このような大きなプロジェクトパリに行くというあのプロジェクトじゃなくてもいいん
例えば地元の商店街で一緒にお祭りをつくってみたりとか
一緒に
仲間で集まって避難所に行ってお年寄りと会話するとかもっと小さくいけば委員会活動
とか部活を活性化するでもいいんです
ほんの小さな一歩があれいつ間にかいろんな人が巻き込まれてくれている
遠くへのアクションになっている
そんなことに怒ると思います
私は
こういったことを伝えたくてこの場に来ました
沢山のアクションを起こすこと一歩踏み出してみること行動してみることで
ちょっとつまらなかった毎日が刺激的な毎日なります
みんなも一緒に行動してみませんかアクションしてみませんか
僕もこれから引き続き行動していくつもりです
ありがとうございました